[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es wieder ein
nachgemacht original trifft sich
gewünscht dass ich auch mal
backmischungen nachmacher also habe ich
mir eine ausgesucht die edgar zitronen
wolke
ich kenne den kuchen da ist wirklich
super locker und super lecker meine
cousine bank nämlich nur mit
backmischungen daher weiß ich mit kuchen
schmeckt das ist übrigens eine
unbezahlte produktplatzierung denn ich
habe dieses produkt selbst gekauft weil
ich vielleicht noch dazu sagen und der
morath der darf dann später die
blindverkostung machen okay ich habe
jetzt hier diese backmischung da stehen
die zutaten und hier muss man nur
schlagsahne und einzufügen und deswegen
habe ich natürlich meinen tag meine
masse auch mit sahne und ich werde das
jetzt hoffentlich so auch die nage treu
wie möglich hin bekommen also ich bin
gespannt
für meine version braucht er viel eiweiß
eine prise salz 80 gramm puderzucker 430
gramm puderzucker etwas vanille extrakt
und zitronen passte 170 gramm sahne 250
gramm mehl und zwei teelöffel backpulver
ich mache das jetzt so in dieser
schüssel hier schlage ich jetzt das
eiweiß steif gemeinsam mit dem salz
mache ich jetzt damit der kuchen
wirklich wirklich locker wird wobei ich
glaube wenn man die eier wir beim bis
mit lange genug aufschlägt kommt sie
jetzt auch ohne eier trennen
ich habe ich jetzt alles drin schlag das
hier steigt und kann aber jetzt schon
mal parallel arbeiten und hier die
eigelbe reingeben gemeinsam mit der
großen menge puderzucker
also ich habe ich die kleine menge die
brauchen das eiweiß und die große menge
hier und kann das jetzt auch schon mal
schön cremig verrühren
[Musik]
der puderzucker rein das eiweiß jetzt
nicht zu steif schlagen also darf so ein
bisschen schmutzig sein tägliches wort
aber ich glaube es beschreibt die
konsistenz die ich brauche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
perfekt weiß cremig schloss sich das
mehl und backpulver habe ich jetzt hier
bereits in einem sieb ich gebe es hier
aber mal die sahne dazu ein rohr sie
kurz ein den kbc im prinzip stabs öl
oder butter und noch mädels einfach
sahne steht nämlich genügend fett und
dann kann man sich zwei zutaten sparen
dann kommt noch etwas milder expected to
sonst wird kelly kuchen und etwas
zitrone passte ihr könnt aber auch
zitronen abschied nehmen natürlich von
zitronen deren schale man verzehren kann
oder ihr nehmt wenn ihr möchtet
zitronenaroma das ist das öl ist auch
mega gut
ich glaube ich gibt es davon noch
zweibrücken zutraulich war nämlich kurz
einrühren
[Musik]
den rest erledige ich jetzt hier mit dem
schneebesen und zwar habe ich jetzt hier
etwas mehr reinkommen bisschen 1 0 1
das mache ich jetzt so im zwei drei
portionen
[Musik]
ist drastisch erhöht die menge der sahne
auf 200 gramm
denn mister noch ein bisschen zu
dickflüssig ich meine das ist ein
experiment ich mache den kurven heute
auch zu werfen
jetzt will ich dir mach sich hier ein in
meinem back ringen den habe ich auf 26
cm eingestellt und mit backpapier
eingeschlagen
[Musik]
und auf der verpackung steht da ist ja
noch für deko schnee drin also süßer
schnee und davon soll man die hälfte
direkt drauf geben also drauf 7
[Musik]
jetzt kommt er direkt in den
vorgeheizten ofen bei 160 grad in die
untere einschub leiste und während
dieser hier packt kann ich mich schon
mal um die backmischung kümmern
ofen vorheizen backmischung in einer
rührschüssel geben
sahne und einzufügen mit einem mixer
kurz auf niedrigster stufe und dann drei
minuten auf höchster stufe
das klingt einfach das schaffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
stelle den timer auf drei minuten
[Musik]
drei minuten sind die teig distanz
richtig cool
die es einfach so ziemlich okay und
jetzt hier auch einfach in den boxring
ein film
[Musik]
etwas verstreichen
[Applaus]
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt also erreicht
auch schon richtig lecker zitrone und
dann gucken wir gleich nach dem backen
hier schmeckt und nach dem backen löse
ich direkt den rand mit einem back for
messer bei beiden und dann wird probiert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt sind beide kuchen fertig habe
jetzt beide mit glitzer schnee bestreut
damit eben auch das ergebnis nicht
verfälscht wird einen einzigen optischen
unterschied gibt der hier ist ein
bisschen heller etwas gelber meiner ist
etwas dunkler und der ist ein bisschen
eingerissen und beim backen ich finde
aber das lag daran dass datei geben die
masse so fest war also falls ihr den
nach backen wollte mit der backmischung
dann macht am besten schuss mehr seine
reihen damit einfach die masse bisschen
flüssiger wird deswegen habe ich ja bei
mir freuen auch mehr sein damit es eben
nicht einreißt morath dennis einmal
bitte in die küche heute gibt's
zitronenkuchen 1 ist eine backmischung 1
ist selbst gemacht
ich sage euch nicht was was ist so paus
fragend für session findet ihr optisch
beide gut ich hab immer noch da aber der
schon mal sehr gut aus schon häufig oder
passt werde ich auf der iss ein bisschen
dunkler oder aber nur auszubauen
ich hab's aber im gleichen balkonen
gemarkung nacheinander nur denn ich
wollte wirklich das ergebnis nicht
verfälschen
also rein sondern hätte schon optisch
musiker sorgten übrig dem moratorium
spitzelte spitze abgebrochen das aber
nicht schlimm
ok zieht auch luftig ausprobieren jetzt
mal gelesen ja am besten ist außen stück
weil ich finde außen stücke ja wenn dann
beide aus der mitte teller weiß ihr
wisst bescheid teller schwarz ihr wisst
bescheid
ich würde sehr gut nach ihnen
man spreche jetzt auch
wir zählen 3 2 1 und dann zeigt er auf
den teller welcher euch jetzt besser
geschmeckt hat 321 jetzt aufgrund der
bräunung vielleicht ist er jetzt für
mich so froh dass ich auch gemacht
der staat müsse die bank manchmal nicht
so lecker und der schwäbische richtig
luft die ich richtig eine wolke also es
deswegen muss jeder für sich selbst
entscheiden jetzt habt ihr die
möglichkeit alles auszuprobieren
ich bin jedenfalls hier wirklich super
luftig super locker aber der hat einfach
eine saftige konsistenz ok probiert
gerne einfach aus und werde sagt 'mensch
sally hier gibt's noch ein produkt oder
ein lebensmittel eine backmischung
probiert doch mal aus macht die man nach
für uns dann schreibt sie mir gerne in
die kommentare dann mache ich das
natürlich
[Musik]
[Applaus]